north korea has fired a long-range
missile in what japan is calling an
unacceptable act of violence japanese
defense officials say it may be a new
type of intercontinental ballistic
missile tokyo says the projectile flew
for over an hour and landed some 150
kilometers off of japan's west coast in
the country's territorial waters if
that's confirmed it would be pyongyang's
first intercontinental ballistic missile
test since 2017.
we can speak to correspondent frank
smith in seoul for more on this story hi
frank so north korea has launched this
long-range missile successfully for the
first time in four years why
well uh right now we're you know the
world's attention really is captured by
what's going on with the war in ukraine
and a lot of people might think this has
something to do with that i'm not really
sure that's the case while this is you
know it's been four years since north
korea launched a long-range
intercontinental ballistic missile it's
done 12 missile tests so far
this year if we go back to you know when
north korea previously launched such a
missile back in 2017 or so in 2018 it
had a summit kim jong-un the leader of
north korea had a summit with former u.s
president donald trump there kim agreed
to suspend essentially a moratorium on
long-range missile launches and nuclear
tests he's kept his word so far in
return he expected a change in what
north korea calls the hostile policy of
the united states specifically north
korea is talking about the sanctions the
united nations security sanctions that
remain on north korea otherwise
right now we just had an election here
in south korea a new conservative
president that vows to take a hard line
with north korea yoon seokyol has come
to power here so this is also a message
to south korea and to the united states
that it wants to see some negotiations
on sanctions relief but frank we've also
seen south korea answer here with its
own barrage of missiles i mean what is
the risk of this really escalating
well when we go back to the cold war and
mutual assured destruction of the soviet
union in the united states
it took a half an hour for an
intercontinental ballistic missile to
get from one of those countries
to another to a population center
here the risk is so much greater we're
talking about neighboring countries and
now we have the development of
hypersonic missiles that take only 90
minutes to make it from pyongyang to
seoul and north korea has been
testing those hypersonic missiles quite
recently so the chance of a
miscalculation
is really increased when we're talking
about countries that are so close in the
development of these
more swifter and more dangerous missiles
correspondent frank smith speaking to us
from seoul thank you very much